PAUL FREEDMAN: But the
advantage of talking to you,
even on an inconvenient day,
is Diocletian.
We don't use terms in the
professional world of history
like awesome very much.
But the guy certainly
deserves that.
He rescued the Roman Empire, and
we'll begin by saying what
he rescued it from.
As a preliminary, the sections
are meeting this week.
If you're wait-listed for
a section, just go to it.
We will have enough sections for
however many people take
this course, right?
So there are currently four.
The additional ones that were
added since last week are
Wednesday at 2:30 and
Thursday at 7:00.
And again, if you're
wait-listed, just go.
We'll figure this out.
There will be enough sections
for everybody.
So I referred last time to
the third century crisis.
A crisis of the Roman Empire
that preceded the accession of
Diocletian, from 235 to 284.
And we mentioned several
interrelated weaknesses of the
Empire that might be
seen as long-term
causes of this crisis.
The size of the Empire.
It's sheer, massive size.
The problem the succession.
That is, it was never quite
clear, and we'll talk about
this in more detail, how one
emperor succeeded another.
The urban-rural imbalance.
This was an empire
built on cities.
And to some extent, although
heavily debated among
historians to what extent, but
to some extent, the cities may
be said to have drained off the
energy, or been parasites
to the productivity of
the countryside.
It was an empire that was,
according to one point of
view, more cosmopolitan than
it had been, according to
another point of view,
more barbarian.
In other words, this was an
empire whose Roman population
was less dominant, partly
through its own success in
co-opting other peoples.
Some of the peoples that it
co-opted we're not actually
originally inhabitants
of the Empire.
Particularly, this is visible in
the armies, which tended to
be staffed by so-called
barbarian tribes.
So called by the Romans,
who referred to them as
barbarians.
Another problem is the East-West
imbalance, where the
East tends to do better
economically and
demographically than the West,
demographically meaning
population.
We live in a world where one
of the great threats is
over-population.
It is therefore not
self-evident, although true,
that for most of the time,
historically, most places have
trouble reproducing
their population.
And indeed, we are starting to
enter into a period of great
demographic decline.
The infant mortality, the low
life expectancy, the death of
women in childbirth, the
prevalence of disease, and to
some extent, military threats
of invasion, or if not
threats, the reality, made it
hard for one generation to
produce children to
replace itself.
And this is true up until
the dawn of modernity.
So these are fundamental
problems of the Roman Empire.
The real question is
why do they explode
in the third century?
And this is a question, as I
think I said last week, with
any great empire.
It's easy to point to the flaws
in a complicated system.
Often size is one of them.
Often bureaucracy.
Often overspending
on the military.
But some of these go on for a
very long time, more or less
success of successfully,
despite the flaws.
And the Roman Empire went on
longer than most, as we said.
The immediate problems that
explode in the third century
are invasions and succession.
Invasions by, first
of all, Persia.
Persia is the old enemy
of the Roman Empire.
Indeed, as many of you know,
the old enemy of the Greek
city-states that precede the
Roman Empire as far back as
the first historian of the
Western tradition, Herodotus--
first week of directed studies,
for those of you who
are nostalgic for that
experience--
Persia is the enemy.
Now we never study Persia.
It's kind of like offstage
all the time.
And that's the great benefit
of the Department of Near
Eastern Languages
and Cultures.
If you want to learn about
Persia really from within,
instead of oh, my god,
the Persians.
And it's oh, my god, the
Persians in 370 BC,
[correction:470]
and it's going to
come to an end.
It is going to come to an end
in the seventh century.
But that's because of Islam,
just to anticipate.
But in the third century, Persia
becomes resurgent.
Having been rather passive, it
has this frontier with the
Roman Empire in the East. More
or less, buffer states are
Mesopotamia, present-day
Iraq, and Armenia.
It's not exactly the same as
the present-day state of
Armenia, but more like
eastern Turkey.
The dynasty that controls
Persia, and that is more
aggressive than its predecessor
are the Sassanids,
and this appears in
your reading.
The Sassanid Dynasty, the rulers
of Persia, just more
aggressive and more
adventurous.
Beginning in 224, they start to
probe that frontier along
the Armenian and Mesopotamian
border, and eventually cross
it and start to wreak havoc in
some of the eastern provinces
of the Roman Empire.
The climax of this is the
Emperor Valerian was captured
by the Persians in 260.
Valerian actually one of the
longer-reigning Emperor's of
this chaotic period,
253 to 260.
They kept him for
a little while.
Displayed him in chains,
maybe flayed him.
Anyway, he died in captivity.
They did a kind of
a job on him.
I think maybe he was flayed
after he died, just not to be
too gruesome, but I think
they displayed the skin.
As I said, I'm not a
Persian specialist.
But the second invasion
is across the
Danube-Rhine frontier.
The Danube and the Rhine form
what the Romans thought of as
a natural frontier with
the barbarian states.
That didn't mean that they
didn't cross them.
In fact, many of their great
fortresses and establishments
were on the eastern
side of the Rhine.
But they considered those as
bulwarks against a dramatic
invasion across the Rhine.
The Rhine and the Danube
almost meet--
the Rhine going from modern
Netherlands down to
Switzerland, and the Danube
going also from Germany
eventually Austria, Hungary,
into the Black Sea.
As we'll see, Charlemagne, in
the early ninth century, tried
to build a canal between
the two of them.
And there are actually traces of
this immense and completely
unsuccessful project.
And there now is a canal
between them.
So this is sort of the frontier
of the Roman Empire,
and this is the line above which
wine grapes are grown,
[correction: wine grapes
become scarce]
no olive oil is pressed.
And it's got to be protected,
but not worth conquering.
So we have pressure on the
Rhine-Danube frontiers in the
third century, and another
Emperor, Decius, died fighting
the Goths in 251, Decius.
And Valerian dies in 260.
So the Emperors are certainly
out there as leaders, but that
actually has to do with
the fact that
they're military guys.
And that is part
of the problem.
The major problem besides the
invasions was succession.
It depends on how you count--
is someone a real Emperor, or
is he merely a pretender?--
there are at least 30 Emperors
between 235 and 285.
Many of them ruling
for months, most
of them being killed.
They're assassinated by the
Praetorian Guard, that is, by
their own troops.
They're killed in battle against
foreign enemies, like
Decius and Valerian.
They're killed in battle against
other people claiming
to be Emperors.
But the most common thing is
they're assassinated by their
own troops.
How had Roman Emperors
succeeded each other?
There were several ways.
One is what you would expect,
and that is dynastic.
But that's not all
that common.
Dynastic, in other words,
families rule.
And the family is recognized
as a ruling family, and
therefore it goes from father to
son, or if there's no son,
father to person daughter
marries, or father to nephew,
something like that.
But that was not actually
so common.
Sometimes the next Emperor was
chosen by his predecessor.
This is characteristic of the
second century AD, the era of
the so-called good Emperors.
In theory, this is
a great system.
You have no family prejudice.
You simply, as a good Emperor,
pick someone who looks to you
like he's going to be
a good Emperor.
So that is another
possibility.
Another possibility is some guy
is powerful, and uses his
troops to take over.
And that's what we see
in the third century.
We see not only the
militarization of the Empire,
but the interference of the army
in raising successors, in
raising new Emperors.
The army was able to make
and unmake Emperors.
Just as in some countries with
unstable political structures,
the military is able to make
and unmake rulers.
What is interesting about the
third century is that they're
able to do it far from Rome.
Some of these armies are
in North Africa.
Some of them are
on the frontier
fighting the Persians.
Rome is becoming less and less
relevant as the dominant city
of the Empire.
And I mentioned that now,
because we'll see on Wednesday
the result of this is will be
the establishment of another
capital, a second capital in
the East, in what would be
called Constantinople,
modern Istanbul.
Rome is fortified for
the first time.
There is a wall that you can
still see in many parts of
Rome, built by the Emperor
Aurelian in 271.
And this is a significant thing,
because until 271 for
centuries, Rome had not been
walled, because it was not
threatened.
And fortification in 271 starts
to indicate things to
come, or at least things that
we know are to come.
Namely, barbarian invasions,
just as the marginalization of
Rome begins at this time.
Rome in the third century is
ruled, if one can call it
that, by a succession
of generals.
Not members of an upper class
elite, but men who have come
from the provinces.
Men who are not particularly
well-educated, who would have
trouble recognizing a tag from
Horace, there being no
internet just to look
these quotes up.
They hold the traditional
Roman elite in contempt.
The Senate of Rome is the
embodiment of that elite.
The Roman Senate is a collection
of extremely
wealthy people, from good
families, extensive property,
and very, very fine education.
The people leading in the third
century now are generals
raised by their troops.
One of the reasons that the
troops both raised up
generals, and then killed them,
was that they tended to
get a kind of reward from
the new Emperor--
a thing called a donative.
A donative is money
that you get when
there's a new Emperor.
A bad idea from the point of
view of the Emperors, because
it encourages double-dipping,
or triple-dipping.
OK, now we've gotten our money
from this guy, let's kill him
and get money from
another guy.
I don't think that's too cynical
to say that that is
some of what is going on.
Now of all the crises of the
third century, this is the one
that leaves the most
visible impression.
There's absolutely no doubt that
there are all of these
different Emperors, and
that the top of the
government is unstable.
The question is how much does
that carry over into the lives
of ordinary people?
One measure of the effectiveness
of a
civilization is that is
survives, and even people
don't comment very much on
political instability.
In a way, we are testing
that now.
For many people, the fact that
the government is polarized
doesn't really matter, in terms
of their everyday life.
How long can that go on?
That's partly because all sorts
of institutions are
functioning perfectly fine.
Here we are.
We are meeting.
There's no problem of the supply
of water suddenly, or
scarce provisioning, or
barbarians massed outside, and
we have to sort of protect
against during our class.
It hasn't come to that.
Yet.
But if you look at the lives
of ordinary people in the
third century, they are not
saying not another Emperor, I
can't take it anymore.
The philosopher Plotinus, for
example, one of the great
intellectual figures
of this time.
Now it's true, he has a very
otherworldly way of thinking
about things.
He is a follower of Plato, he's
the leading so-called
neo-Platonist philosopher,
flourishes during the third
century, travels a bit.
But we never hear of any
difficulty, any kind of
problems raised by these
unstable conditions.
The one that might have affected
more people than the
instability is inflation.
Roman coinage was silver and
bronze, and based on ratios of
these metals to gold.
The ultimate standard of value
was gold, but bronze and
silver had attributed values
in relation to gold.
The need to reward the army with
those donatives, and the
dislocations of the invasions
led to tremendous government
expenditures.
And this was a society that did
not have debt financing.
There are no bonds.
There are no ways of the
government anticipating future
revenues and borrowing
money against them.
That is actually an invention
of the Middle Ages.
This is an example of something
that the Romans
didn't have that Medieval cities
in Italy pioneered,
debt financing.
I don't have to tell
you what that is.
And it's a great advantage,
up to a point.
Great advantage, because it
gives you leverage, allows you
to do things now.
So how does a government deal
with problems like this if it
can't borrow money?
It does what is called
debasing the coinage.
To debase, that is degrade,
the coinage means that you
just don't put in as much silver
or bronze, let alone
gold, and try to get
people to accept it
for its value anyway.
So up until the 1970s, the
American currency was based on
gold, and dollar bills were
called silver certificates.
They said that you could hand
this bill in for a dollar's
worth of silver.
It was, technically speaking,
not currency.
It was merely a representative
of currency, which
you could trade in.
And before that, of course,
the coins were metal.
Dollars were both silver and
paper, with the silver one
being, in some sense,
the more real.
It is in the nature of modern
government financing that, at
some point, the government
could just say
forget about it.
And even long before the
1970s, of course the
government didn't have enough
silver for everyone to trade
them in, just as it doesn't have
enough gold in Fort Knox
to float the entire
world's currency.
It has a lot.
And that's important that there
be some real kind of
value, or bullion, or bottom
line kind of gold bars.
But the fact that it's
not enough is not
intrinsically a problem.
But here, so let's say the
government receives, in the
form of taxes and stuff,
a thousand gold units.
And it issues two thousand
units using that gold.
The coins say they're worth a
unit, but they're actually, in
terms of precious metal
value, worth a half.
So it pays its expenses
that way.
It pays the army.
It gets people to accept
this money.
But when most people go to buy
stuff, they are going to find
that the stuff is 50% more
expensive, because their coins
are not actually very good.
The governments tend to do this
gradually, hoping the
people don't notice in the first
place, or that if the
inflation is say, 10%,
it's not so bad.
But once having embarked on the
debasement of the coinage,
this tends to get out of control
because of the famous
Gresham's law-- an 18th
century economist--
that bad money drives
out good.
If I have good sestertia, or
Roman currency, with the full
measure of silver that they say
they have, one full unit,
and I've got other coins that
say one full unit, but only
have half, I'm going to try to
get rid of the bad ones and
hoard the good ones.
And only spend the good ones
if I absolutely have to, or
demand a premium on them.
So therefore, there are all
these crappy coins circulating
like mad, and the good ones
retreat into peoples' wealth--
they don't really have
mattresses then-- but into
their store boxes, or under
their beds, creating in itself
more and more inflation.
So you have a fierce
inflation.
Prices go up.
People don't know the
value of things.
They start bartering.
And the Roman economy is very,
very adversely affected, as
hyperinflation tends to.
And a final problem is the
ruin of the local elite,
partly because of this economic
chaos, but partly
from deeper causes.
The importance of this is
something that I alluded to
last time, and that is that the
Empire could not be held
together, really, by the
government, however big the
government was.
It required the cooperation of
wealthy people with ties to
their native city.
It was these people who
sponsored games, civic
improvements, maintained the
temples, and kept a kind of
local order.
The third century crisis
undermines this elite.
This elite is undermined by the
militarization of society.
They are, to some extent,
ruined by taxation and
increased taxation.
They're just powerful enough
to be well-off, but not
powerful enough to
evade taxation.
But they also tend to be
undermined by an Empire that's
more cosmopolitan, where local
elites don't matter as much.
Where, for example, military
people who move around a lot,
are more important.
And I emphasize this, not only
because of these elites
themselves and their role in
holding the Empire together,
but we're going to talk about
this when we talk about
Christianity.
Because when the local
elites are
ruined, so is local religion.
And local religion
means polytheism.
If I am of a grand family of,
let's say the city of Sardis
in Asia Minor, in modern Turkey,
and I feel that my
ancestors have always been
involved in the worship of the
goddess Cybele and I am a
votary, or an officer, or like
a member of the governing board
of the club, or society
that runs the cult of Cybele,
I'm going to feel very loyal
to that local deity.
But if I come from North Africa,
and I'm in Sardis
because that's where my army
is, I'm not going to don't
care about some local.
No more than you might care
about a club that's important
at Yale, if you went to the
University of Illinois.
No more important than you might
feel about pizza in New
Haven, if you came from
somewhere else
and didn't like pizza.
It's just like this local cult,
and you don't understand
it, and you don't care.
So the kind of things you will
care about, we'll see,
religiously.
But they will tend to be
religions that cross borders,
like Christianity.
Religions that are not
identified with one place and
one god, in the sense of local
god, local temple, my people.
So into this mess Diocletian--
because Diocletian defeats his
predecessor, Carinus
in battle in 284.
Diocletian is a general.
In 284, it would have seemed
like more of the same.
But Diocletian rules until
305 and he abdicates.
He passes the power
to someone else.
He is, however, very typical
of the military
class of the Empire.
He came from nowhere,
socially.
He was the son of an ex-slave
from Dalmatia,
modern coastal Croatia.
You can still see his palace in
the Croatian city of Split
on the Adriatic.
His retirement palace,
actually.
Under his severe guidance,
the Empire was reformed.
And the way it was reformed was
that it was, in effect,
militarized.
Diocletian was not a great
general, but he was a
brilliant manager.
And he was a brilliant
bureaucratic organizer.
I used the term bureaucracy,
not to mean inefficient,
useless administration,
but administration.
Administration officers of the
state, who are capable of
doing their jobs, or maybe not
capable of doing their jobs.
But who are nevertheless--
I'm not making a value judgment
with the term
bureaucracy--
I simply mean the proliferation
of government
and government offices.
Diocletian is responsible for
the militarization of society.
That is, building society around
the army in order to
protect it.
And he is responsible for
a more efficient, and
ultimately, burdensome
form of taxation.
The two are enlinked because, as
we know, you have to pay to
have a large and effective
military.
Diocletian did not set out
to be a revolutionary.
His aims were conservative.
He wanted to save, preserve,
restore, the Roman Empire of
the pre-235 era.
His methods were radical.
He was willing to undertake
radical measures.
And the debate among
historians,
now somewhat muted.
Many historians at one time
felt that he had basically
destroyed the Empire.
By making it so bureaucratic,
so militarized, so
heavy-handed, in terms of
government, it no longer was
the Roman Empire.
It was something else.
Now the reason this is no longer
exactly considered to
be a big problem, or a big
controversy, you'll see when
we come to read Wickham.
The Empire has an impress
on society.
There is what he calls the
Burden of Empire, but it is,
at the same time, not a
totalitarian empire that
controls everything.
Society has an identity that's
different from the government.
So he has three goals.
One, solving this problem of
the imperial succession.
Two, stabilizing the economy.
Three, protecting
the frontiers.
Of these three, he's actually
only really successful in the
third, protecting
the frontiers.
He devises a system, that we're
going to talk about in a
moment, of succession, but
it does not really
outlast him very long.
The economy does get fixed but,
not exactly because of
his policies.
What he's really successful
at, and what changes most
dramatically, is what
rulership means.
That includes the figure of the
Emperor, who becomes more
sacred and more powerful, in
terms of imagery, as well as
administration.
Changes in the administration,
of taxes in particular, and
then that goal of his to change
and grow the military.
The size of the army grew,
probably doubled.
Maybe, just as a ballpark
figure, from 200,000 troops to
400,000 troops.
This is a major, major
increase that
had to be paid for.
And it had to be paid for
by taxation, and from a
population not particularly
eager to
volunteer to pay more.
Ultimately, it looks as if
Diocletian didn't so much
increase taxation, as increase
the efficiency of its
collection.
In order to increase the
efficiency of his collection,
he had to increase the
bureaucracy charged with
monitoring the taxes.
And that means first making an
inventory of taxable resources.
There is no income tax in this
society because it's an
economy based more on land
than on salaries.
An income tax is easy because
you can keep records of what
people are earning.
The government, to this day,
finds it much easier to take a
portion of your wages, because
it knows from your company
what you're being paid.
If you're being paid in some
other form, like you're a
waiter, and a lot of your
money is in tips, that's
harder for the government.
If your wealth is in property,
it's hard to
put a value on that.
You own estates.
You have people who are free
tenants, who rent land from
you, and pay you in money,
or produce, or labor.
You have some slaves.
You have a water mill.
How do you pay taxes on
all of this stuff.
The opportunities for
evasion are greater.
So the first bureaucratic tasks
was just to have a lot
of people could value things,
who could come into a
territory and say OK, this farm
is worth so much, and it
has these many people.
They develop a system to
evaluate productive units of
things like land, and
population, and to tax them
according to a formula.
So I have a lot of land, but
it's not very good land.
I don't have a lot of people
making a living off it.
I will be taxed at a lower rate
than someone was maybe
half that land, but twice the
people, better soil, more
clearance of forest, whatever
the reason.
It changes.
So every 15 years, the
government changes its
estimation.
A second means, once you have
this taxation system in place,
of bringing the Empire together
and dominating it
more, is to have the army really
have first call on the
resources of the state.
We now start to have a
state supply system
for the army alone.
This allows the state to
avoid dealing with
that debased currency.
So for example, the state just
goes in and takes wheat and
gives it to the army, without
taking money, buying wheat,
giving that to the army.
Diocletian binds the Empire
together, also very
effectively, by a
postal system.
Post in this case meaning a
system of riders, horses,
communications, that allows the
Emperor to go faster than
anyone else, to have news
quicker than anyone else, to
send orders quicker
than anyone else.
And also, more punishment for
things like tax evasion.
It's not just that people get
killed for not paying their
taxes, or imprisoned, or
tortured, but that groups are
responsible.
Not only that if I don't pay my
taxes, I get punished, but
if you and I live in the same
village, and you don't pay
your taxes, I get punished.
Or at the very least, taxed for
the part that you evaded.
But the most important change
in government is the
establishment of what's
called the Tetrarchy.
The Tetrarchy is the
rule of four.
Four rulers Diocletian divides
the Empire, first in two--
East, West. A very significant
move that will have
consequences for the
next 1,200 years.
He then appoints a co-Emporer to
rule in the West, while he
rules in the East. And they each
appoint a helper, number
three and number four.
The two Emperors are called
Augusti, Emperors, and the two
helpers are Caesars.
So they're subordinate to their
respective Augusti, and
they're supposed to help them.
Why this system?
This is really to overcome
the problems of size,
communication, administration.
It's a statement that the
Empire is too big
for one man to rule.
But the chief Emperors
are also exalted now.
There's no longer
a pretense that
they're just first citizens.
or princes.
They are clothed in purple.
They don't move a lot
in public audiences.
We're familiar with this kind
of dichotomy between the
political figure as distant
authority, versus the
political figure at least
pretending to be just
like you and me.
We're in the era
of the latter.
The Diocletianic period ushers
in a period when the Emperor
is distant, glimpsed, product
of ceremonies, wearing a lot
of very funny-looking,
but fancy clothes.
He doesn't appear
a lot in public.
He's a god.
You don't go up to him and
shake hands, or say hi.
You throw yourself at his feet,
and don't look at him
until he tells you to.
So the tetrarchy, great idea,
it really doesn't work.
Because, first of all,
the Emperors
don't necessarily cooperate.
The Caesars don't necessarily
cooperate with the Emperors.
And so in 285 Diocletian
nominates a Caesar, and then
makes him, in 286,
a co-Augustus.
And this man is named
Maximian.
In 293, Diocletian and Maximian
appoint two Caesars.
I think I'm not going to burden
you with the personnel.
I will hand out something on
Wednesday that gives you some
of this information.
Diocletian and Maximian appoint
Galerius in the East
and Constantius in the Western--
you don't have to
remember who these are--
and each of them marries
a daughter of
their respective Augusti.
This looks like a
great system.
In 305, Diocletian and Maximian
abdicate and then two
people become Augusti.
The two Caesars rise up to be
Augusti and they appoint their
own new Caesars.
It breaks down beginning
in 306.
One of the sons of one of
these Augusti is not
appointed, and he's mad,
and he revolts.
And then the Augusti
don't get along.
Out of this chaos between 306
and 312 emerges one Emperor.
And that is Constantine.
And we'll be talking about
Constantine on Wednesday.
So the Tetrarchy fails.
Diocletian's second big
initiative was over this
question of the economy, and
ways of combating inflation.
Diocletian issued a so-called
edict on prices.
The edict on prices
attempted to set a
fixed price for goods.
And if you sold them for more
than that, you were to be
severely punished.
This is the kind of classic
example of the state trying to
combat inflation by
dictating prices.
Most of you are not familiar
with inflation, because we
have lived in an era of
very low interest and
fairly stable prices.
But if you think of those
commodities whose inflation
you are familiar with, like
petroleum, it is very
dislocating.
It starts to create panics, and
the panics then feed into
the inflation.
Just as, if people keep on
getting gas because they think
that it's going to go up in
price, then there's a greater
demand for gasoline, and it
goes up further in price.
Eventually, if the thing is
really just speculative, it
deflates again.
And that's what's happened
with products that we're
familiar with in recent times.
But there is also a kind of
structural, longer-term
inflation such as America
experienced, for
example, in the '70s.
And in theory, if you have
resource crises and things
that are becoming scarcer, then
you ought to have more
and more experience
with inflation.
The government in the 1970s in
the United States tried also
to have an edict on prices.
Under President Ford, there was
a kind of administration
of maximum prices.
The problem with this is that
it creates a temptation for
black markets, creates a version
of what we were just
talking about with Gresham's
law of coinage.
If you say that tomatoes can
only be sold for a dollar a
pound, then those tomatoes
that are being sold for a
dollar a pound in a climate of
severe inflation will be
terrible, will be rotten.
If you want to pay $2.00 a pound
in secret, we have some
nice tomatoes for you.
And if you want to pay $5.00 a
pound, we have some really
nice, locally-grown
tomatoes for you.
All of which may be illegal, but
the legal market is empty.
And this is what happened
in response to
the edict of prices.
This doesn't mean that the
government cannot--
I mean it still remains
debatable, obviously, the
degree to which government
can or cannot
intervene in such things--
but certainly, in the case of
the Roman Empire, this failed.
What did bring back a measure
of economic stability is the
reform of the taxation.
The fact that the state simply
started getting in more
resources, that less was being
withheld by private people,
and so the state could
actually pay for its
administrative and
military costs.
So Diocletian succeeded in
abdicating peacefully, spent
his retirement in Split in his
palace, and lived to see the
breakdown, or the partial
breakdown of the Tetrarchy.
And in certain respects, his
policies clearly failed.
The edict on prices had to be
abandoned, the Tetrarchy did
not work, and Diocletian failed
in trying to suppress
Christianity.
We'll talk about this some more,
but Diocletian, in the
late part of his reign, a couple
animals were split open
to see what the future
would be.
Right?
Isn't that what we all do if you
want to figure out what's
going to happen?
You slaughter an animal and
check out its liver.
Maybe its kidneys
and spleen, too.
But the liver is really what
you want to look at.
And I don't exactly know what
the animal was, what the
organs were, and why they didn't
splay out right, but
the liver told Diocletian
that the Christians were
responsible for this, and that
he'd better go after them.
So there is this big persecution
of Christians in
the first part of the
fourth century.
And he certainly didn't
succeed in that.
Not only did the Christians
not crumble, but of course
Diocletian's most effective
successor, six years after he
abdicated, would convert
to Christianity.
But Diocletian is extremely
important, and in many
respects, extremely
successful.
He did more than prop up
a tottering Empire.
He did more than just transform
a tottering Empire
into a kind of tottering
tyranny.
He saved the Roman Empire.
He saved the Roman Empire
for 100 years.
When you take a course like this
that goes for 700, 800
years, you start to hurl
centuries around and get
confused among them.
But any polity that exists
for 100 years is fairly
impressive.
Or a polity that looks like it's
about to collapse, and
then is restored
for 100 years.
The Roman Empire, conventionally
speaking, is
thought to have collapsed
in the West in
the late fifth century.
In the East however, arguably,
Diocletian's reforms last for
more on the order
of 1,200 years.
The Eastern Empire, the
Byzantine Empire
would fall in 1453.
And to its last day, it was
modeled on Diocletianic
administrative and
military forms.
People at the time clearly
thought that they'd been saved
from disaster.
If you look at fourth century
artifacts, things like mosaics
on the floors of dining rooms,
people often put mottos there.
And their mottos are things
like "Joyful times
everywhere." or "A world
restored." The fourth century
is interpretable as an era of
increasing gloom, because we
know that in the fifth century
things are going to collapse.
But people in the fourth century
are not saying to each
other, I'm so glad I'm alive in
the fourth century, because
I don't want to see what's going
to happen in the fifth.
They are just happy that the
barbarians are back across the
Danube and the Rhine, the
Persians are more or less
controlled along the frontier.
Yes, taxes are high.
Yes, the elite is some sort of
riff-raff, and not as well
educated, and they're
military people.
But basically, things are
working, prosperity is
restored to the people who had
been prosperous before, the
local elites have declined,
but it's not so
visible as it had been.
But there are some changes.
Changes that we can, with the
proverbial benefit of
hindsight, see.
Changes in the center
of gravity.
The dominant places are
now places that
are military bases.
They are great cities, with
all the amenities of Rome.
That is, stadiums, gateways.
One of the best-preserved
of these to this
day is Trier in Germany.
Trier, on the Moselle behind
[correction: west of]
the Rhine, has a wonderful
collection of Roman ruins.
A gateway, the Porta Nigra, a
theater, a sports arena, a
basilica, a law court turned
into a church.
The reason trier was great was
because of the frontier.
It was one of the most important
cities in the Empire
because of the military, because
of its strategic
importance.
And there are other cities
that are like.
Milan, for example, becomes
more important than Rome.
Because Milan is further north,
it's a good place to
get to the Danube and to the
Rhine quickly, whereas Rome is
buried in the Mediterranean.
So we're in a new world.
We'll discuss more of the
new world on Wednesday.
And we will see that
Constantine, in some cases,
completely revolutionizes
things.
And in other cases, continues
Diocletian's work.